hey guys welcome back today we're going
to talk about how to get rid of your
mucus especially in the sinuses now in
the sentences you have an internal
lining of skin that's called a mucous
membrane and it's highly sensitive to
irritants and allergies so you're going
to have to find out if there's an
allergy or is it just always stuffy all
year around now it could be either a
food allergy or environmental you'll
know if it's environmental if it's food
every time you consume milk or grains
you get stuffy or sugar so if that's the
case you're going to have to avoid that
right now now there's these little cells
in the mucous membrane called goblet
cells and that's the cell that makes the
mucus and it's controlled by vitamin A
so what what I would do if are you if
you have this problem and start making
sure you have enough vitamin A and the
diet other symptoms of vitamin A
deficiency would be night blindness you
can't see at night in the dark that
would be a symptom a lot of problems
with skin but vitamin A primarily the
active form is called retinol if you eat
if you're vegetarian you're not really
going to get as much of the active form
you only probably orb by 4% but vitamin
A is in like cod liver oil it's in
butter it's grass-fed and grass-fed
dairy that you might be allergic to but
it's in a lot of animal products so
because it's a fat soluble vitamin now
if you're taking and I recommend if you
want a really good source about them and
I get the virgin cod liver oil it's the
best vitamin A it's great to take during
winter to help for the immune system
cold but it's it's really awesome
now also believe it or not grass-fed
butter has vitamin A - you can do that
but here's this thing that I'm finding
if you're taking vitamin A and it's
still not working
it could be that your gall bladder
doesn't digest vitamin A - well because
you might be missing the bile B il eat
that helps you absorb it so you always
want to make sure if the person has a
like if you have no gall bladder yep
loading after you eat you have
constipation you have Rachel the pain
all the symptoms of low bile then that
means you're going to have to take bio
to be able to absorb it and that way you
primarily need vitamin A you just need
to take a little bile salts to be able
to pull it in I put a little link down
below for more information on bile if
you've never heard about that so so
those are the two things now there is
one more thing there's another thing in
the in the sinuses called microbial
biofilms now what does that mean that is
basically a bunch of microbes that hang
together and live in your sinus cavities
and they create like all sorts of mucous
and crusty stuff if you have that which
a lot of people have that there's an
enzyme you can take that's called Sara
pep case get it in two hundred thousand
I use and you want to take this on an
empty stomach it's probably the most
powerful protein enzyme that you can get
and it's going to go in there and start
cleaning the mucus liquefying the mucus
getting out of the the deep sinuses in
other places as well so it's really good
for the lung it's probably one of the
best remedies that I would recommend if
you suffer from a lot of sinus issues
and also sleep apnea okay alright so
hope you hope you got something out of
this and put your comments below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video